The following content it's
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare,
under a Creative
Commons license.
Additional information about our
license and MIT OpenCourseWare,
in general, is available
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Several
pieces of good news.
Since Brett is back now,
all of chapters five and six
of my notes, that is to say,
all that we've covered in class,
plus a little more, are
on the web page now.
So, I was cautious at the
beginning of the semester
and didn't put that up, and then
forgot that it wasn't there.
So now you have
something to work with,
particularly on any
experiments, for example,
minimum degree ordering.
Oh and also,
there's a movie now.
Tim Davis from Florida and
[? Perils ?] [? Person ?],
my friend here, created a little
movie to show the order that
elimination occurs.
And I had a lot of
email with Tim Davis.
On that one-page handout,
for 2D Laplace's equation,
it mentions N cubed for the
nested dissection, where
you cut the region in half, and
half, and half, by separators.
I believe, and I think
experiments will show,
that minimum degree
is even better.
But the analysis is
extremely weak, apparently,
on minimum degree.
So anyway, one possible
project either for now
or for the final project
would be some experiments
to see what the actual
convergence is like.
And maybe a little
understanding of minimum degree.
So we'll talk more about that.
Anyway, there's a movie
and a lot more material
there on the website.
It'll get updated and
corrected as I do the edits.
Second bit of good news.
I made a mistake.
That's not normally good
news, but this time, I
reported a little
calculation for multigrid,
and I computed the wrong thing.
You remember that I computed
M. M was the Jacobi matrix.
So M was the Jacobi matrix, the
iteration matrix with Jacobi,
which is I minus D
inverse A This is
for the 1D second differences.
In fact, this was
the 5 by 5 matrix
that we've been talking about.
And now this is multiplied
by D inverse which is a half,
but then with a weighting
factor, that becomes a third.
So that's weighted Jacobi now.
And this is what we would get
for ordinary, simple iteration.
And it's not satisfactory.
Remember it had an eigenvalue
lambda_max, the spectra radius,
was about 0.9.
Then I reported about
the eigenvalues of M*S,
the multigrid matrix S, M, and
I was a little disappointed
in its eigenvalues.
The reason is, I should
have been doing I
minus S M. When I do that,
I'm not disappointed anymore.
What are the
eigenvalues of this?
You remember, S is the
matrix that tells us
how much error we're capturing.
S is the matrix that came
from-- the error we captured
at the end of
multigrid, was S times
the error that we entered with.
And so the error that's
left, the remaining error,
the new error, is the rest.
It's the part we don't get,
and that's when I forgot.
That's I minus S e.
So that's why I should
have been using I minus S.
So then, the step one of
multigrid does a smoother.
Steps two, three, four
leave me I minus S.
And step five did
another smoother.
And this is just with one Jacobi
step, which you would probably
do three.
Anyway, the eigenvalues
of this were, well --
this has two zero
eigenvalues, and three 1's.
So this matrix has
eigenvalues 0, 0, 1, 1, 1.
Because, why's that?
Well, we get two 0's-- you
remember the eigenvalues had
to be 0 or 1, because
S squared equaled S,
and I minus S squared
equals I minus S. So.
We remember that.
Now, the question
is, what are these?
And the answer is 1/9
is a triple eigenvalue.
I was astonished to discover
1/9-- of course, 0, 0 survived.
The rank is 3.
And this is now
looking much better.
What I reported last time
was some more like 7/8,
or something, and I
thought oh, multigrid,
it's not showing
its true colors.
But actually it does.
This is a kind eigenvalue
we expect, like 1/10,
for a multigrid cycle.
So much better.
If we just did three
M's, for example,
I would get down to 0.9
cubed, which is more than 0.7,
where by doing multigrid
instead, we're down to 0.1.
OK.
So that's the good news.
And, of course, if you
experiment a little,
you'll find different
numbers for different sizes
and really see what's happening.
And, in fact, you could do 2D.
I mentioned all
this partly for now,
if you're wanting to do it
now, or partly for eventually,
later.
Oh, and thinking about projects,
just one word to repeat,
that the Monday
after spring break,
I think that's April
the third, no class.
So it'll be Wednesday
that I'll see you again.
But Mr. [? Cho ?]
will be available.
He has office hours,
so that's April 3,
if you wanted to discuss
issues with your project
with Mr. [? Cho ?], that would
be at class time in his office
2-130, at one o'clock.
Otherwise, take an
extra spring break,
and I'll see you Wednesday.
OK.
So that's various
bits of good news.
Oh.
One other thing that I guess I
didn't finish in that lecture,
was to identify the
two eigenvalues.
Well, eigenvectors.
Those will be in the notes too.
I guess I found one
eigenvector, [1, 2, 2, 2, 1].
And glancing at the matrix,
I didn't spot the other one,
but it has one oscillation.
It's [1, 2, 0, -2, -1].
Anyway, this is the main thing.
A much better result.
So that's multigrid,
which we now can use
as our iteration.
Or we can use it as
a preconditioner.
Many of the
recommended methods use
multigrid as a preconditioner
before something even more
powerful.
Well, I don't know about
even more powerful.
Multigrid people would
say not possible.
But some situations, we may
want to go to a different method
but we want a preconditioner,
and multigrid excellent.
By multigrid, I
include the smoother.
So it'd be that.
That would be a
possible preconditioner
for something else.
OK.
So where are we now?
We're into the new section
starting this moment.
And what's the section about?
It's about things associated
with this name, Krylov.
So, I'm going to use the letter
K for the things that are
associated-- and I'm always
solving A*u equals b.
There's a Krylov matrix
that's created exactly
as you see here.
This is the j-th-- the
one with j columns.
b, A*b, A squared b, up to
A to the the j minus 1 b.
And the Krylov space is the
combinations of those vectors.
That's what this
word, span, means.
I could erase span, and
say, "all combinations of".
Maybe that even more familiar.
So "spanned by"
is the same thing
is saying "all linear
combinations of".
Of those j vectors.
And, of course, that's
the same as saying
it's the column
space of the matrix,
because the column space
is all combinations.
OK.
So, why am I interested?
Why was Krylov interested?
Why is everybody interested
in these vectors?
Because actually, that's what an
iteration like Jacobi produces.
If I use Jacobi's method-- or
Gauss-Seidel, any of those--
after one step, I've got b.
After two steps, there's a
multiplication by A in there,
right?
And some combination
is taken, depending
on the particular method.
So after two steps, I've got
a combination of b and A*b.
After three steps, Jacobi
produces some combination of b,
A*b, A squared b.
In other words, all of
those iterative methods
are picking their
j-th approximation
in this space K_j, actually.
I should put a little j on it,
to indicate that that's-- so we
have these spaces are growing.
They grow by one
dimension, by one new basis
vector at each iteration.
And the point is, Jacobi
makes a particular choice
of x_j or u_j, the
approximation after j steps.
But does it make
the best choice?
Probably not.
In fact, pretty definitely not.
And so the idea is let's
make the best choice.
Let's not just use
a simple iteration
that builds in a choice that
might not be so terrific.
Let's make the best choice.
There are a whole lot of Krylov
methods, which all choose x_j--
since I think this
section will use x,
I'm going to change that to x.
They'll all be iterative.
They'll all start
with x_0 as 0, say.
And then the first
guess will be b, maybe.
Or maybe not.
Maybe some multiple of b.
Actually, a good
Krylov method will
take the best multiple
of b as the first guess,
and not necessarily 1 times b.
And onwards.
So we have this word,
best, coming up.
What's the best
vector in that space?
And there are different
methods depending
on what I mean by best.
Oh, let me tell you
the name of the method
that I'm going to concentrate
on first and most.
Will be the conjugate
gradient method.
CG.
The conjugate gradient method.
What determines x_j?
It chooses x_j in K_j,
the space that we always
look for our approximation in.
Let me not forget to say: these
vectors, b, A*b, A squared b,
and so on, they're
easy to compute,
because each one is just a
matrix multiplication from
the previous one.
And the matrix is--
we're assuming we're
working with sparse matrices.
And mostly, and
especially, sometimes,
especially symmetric ones.
So just let me put in
here, before I even
finish that sentence,
that CG, this
is for A transpose
equal A symmetric.
It's only for those.
And positive definite so
symmetric, positive definite.
So it's a limited class of
problems, but a highly, highly
important class.
And you may say what do
we do if the matrix is
symmetric, but indefinite?
Well, that comes next.
Or what if the matrix is
not to symmetric at all.
Well, if you're brave, you might
try conjugate gradients anyway.
But if you're cautious,
then you would
use one of the other
methods like MINRES.
Maybe I'll just mention one
more on our eventual list.
Actually that tells us
probably what choice it makes.
MINRES chooses the x_j
to minimize the residual.
Minimum r.
Remember r is b minus A*x.
The residual r
will always denote
the error in the equation.
And so it's minimum residual.
OK.
So that's a natural
choice, but you'll
see that this is a
fantastic method.
Superior, just quicker than
MINRES, for a nice reason.
So it chooses x_j in K_j,
and I think the rule it uses
is that I think x_j should be
orthogonal-- I'll go and check
it in my notes-- to
the residual r_j.
Let me just be sure-- if I'm
going to write that down,
I better be sure I
said it correctly.
I actually, I didn't
say it correctly.
r_j is orthogonal to
the whole space K_j.
It turns out that
we can choose x_j--
when I make a choice
of x_j, it's in K_j.
Now when I compute r,
there's a multiplication by A
to get the residual, so that
moves us up to the next space,
and I'm going to
make a choice where
this is orthogonal to
the whole space K_j.
You have to do
conjugate gradient.
And I can't start on
that for a good reason.
I have to start with
something called Arnoldi.
And and what's Arnoldi about?
Well.
Let me come back
to these vectors.
Quick to compute.
But what's the other property?
Everything in applied
numerical mathematics,
you're choosing basis
vectors, and you're
looking for two properties.
And I guess this is like
a general rule, whenever
you meet a whole new
problem, in the end,
you're going to construct
some basis vectors
if you're going to compute.
And what properties
are you after?
You're after speed.
So they have to be quick
to compute and work with.
Well these are.
Multiplying by A is sparse
matrix multiplication,
you can't beat that.
But the other
property that you need
is some decent independence.
And not just barely independent.
You want the condition
number of the basis,
somehow-- if I use
that word-- to be good.
Not enormous.
And best of all, you would
like the basis vectors
to be orthonormal.
That's a condition
number of one.
That's the best basis
you can hope for.
And the point is,
that this construction
produces a lousy basis from
the point of view of condition.
So Arnoldi's job is
orthogonalize the Krylov basis,
which is b, A*b, and so on,
producing orthonormal basis
q_1, q_2, up to q_j.
It's just beautiful.
So Arnoldi's taking
like a preliminary step
that Krylov has to make to
get something that numerically
reasonable to work with.
Then if it's fast, and Arnoldi
doesn't-- we have to do
a multiplication by A,
and you'll see one here
in the middle of Arnoldi--
and then, of course,
if you look at those
ten lines of MATLAB,
and we could go through
them a little carefully,
but let's just
take a first look.
The first step is like
Gram-Schmidt, right?
It's sort of a
Gram-Schmidt idea.
You take that first vector
b, you accept that direction,
and the only step remaining
is to normalize it.
Divide by its length.
Then you go on to the next.
Then you have some
trial vector t,
which would in this case be
A*b, in the direction of A*b,
which won't be orthogonal
to the original b, right?
So this won't be
orthogonal to that one.
So, of course,
you've got to compute
an inner product between them.
And subtract off
the right multiple
of the previous one
from the current t
to get the improved t.
And then you're going
to normalize it again.
So you compute its length
and divide by the length.
You see that overall
pattern in Arnoldi?
It's the familiar idea
of Gram-Schmidt of,
take a new vector,
find its projections
onto the ones that
are already set,
subtract those components
off, you're left with a piece,
and you find its
length and normalize
that to be a unit factor.
It's very familiar.
Its exactly the
type of algorithm
that you would write
down immediately.
And it just involved the
one multiplication by A
so that it's not
going to cost us
a lot to make the
vectors orthonormal.
Well.
Wait a minute.
Is it going to be
expensive or not?
That's like the key question.
It's certainly going to
produce a good result.
Producing orthonormal vectors is
going to be a good thing to do.
But is it expensive or not?
That depends.
It's certainly not expensive
if the new trial vector
t has only components
in one or two
of the already
settled directions.
In other words, if I
only have to subtract off
a couple of earlier
components, then I'm golden.
And that's the case
when A is symmetric.
So that will be
the key point here.
And I just make it here.
If A is symmetric, A transpose
equals A, then I only need,
in this subtracting off, where
I'm headed for the new q,
I only need to subtract off
h_(j, j), multiplying the q_j,
the q that was just
set, and the one before.
h_(j-1, j).
I'll call that a
short recurrence.
It's short because it
only has two terms.
And then there'll
be a new h_(j+1, j),
which is just the length.
So there'll be one of these
magic things in so many parts
of mathematical analysis, a
three-term recurrence relation
will hold-- in fact,
I guess the reason
we see three-term recurrence
relations in all-- Legendre
polynomials,
Chebyshev polynomials,
all those classical
things-- the reason
is actually the
same as it is here.
That something in the
background is symmetric.
I want to put a few
numbers on the board
so you see what is typical
input and output to Arnoldi.
And you'll see it's
symmetric and then you'll
see it's short recurrence,
and then we want to see what?
OK.
So I worked out a
typical Arnoldi example.
Not that one.
Here.
OK.
I think this is a good
example to look at.
So matrix A is not only
symmetric, it's diagonal.
So of course, to find A
inverse b is not difficult.
But we're going to do it
through conjugate gradients.
So that means that we
don't figure out A inverse,
which, of course,
we easily could.
We just use A, very sparse.
Here's our right-hand side.
Here's our Krylov matrix.
It has b in its first column.
It has A times b in
the second column.
Multiply by A again to
get the third column.
And A one more time to
get the fourth column.
So that's K_4, right?
And for a 4 by 4
problem, that's the end.
So actually here I'm carrying
Krylov to the end of it.
There's no more to do.
Because once I've got this
K_j, the combinations of those,
are all of R^4, all of
four-dimensional space.
Oh, yeah.
That raises an important
point about how
we're improving on iterations.
If I was using Jacobi,
or Gauss-Seidel, or one
of those others,
then-- well, I won't
say for this particular A, but
usually-- after four steps,
I am by no means finished.
I've taken four steps,
I've gotten closer,
but I haven't got
the exact answer.
But now, in this the
world of Krylov methods,
after four steps, I will
have the exact answer.
Why?
Because Krylov methods take
the best x_4 out of the space
spanned by those four columns.
Well, the whole space, R^4
is spanned by those columns
and taking the best
one must be the answer.
So x_4 will actually
be A inverse
b, the answer we're looking for.
So these methods are on the
one hand, direct methods.
They finish after
four steps, finish.
You've got the answer.
Now.
That's actually
how they were born.
As direct methods
that gave the answer
from an interesting
iteration and they nearly
died for that reason.
They were born and died,
or were on death's door,
as direct methods.
Because as direct methods,
there are better ones.
Then some years later,
people went back to it, back
to conjugate
gradients, and noticed
that thought of as
just going partway,
gave very successful answers.
So we're going to think
of Krylov-- we're planning
to stop before j equals n.
In this picture, j
equals n equal 4 here.
But, we plan to stop
for j much below n.
We're thinking of applications
where n is 10 the fifth,
and we're going to stop at
10 squared, 100 steps, maybe.
Or ten steps.
So that meant a total
reconsideration,
reanalysis of
conjugate gradients,
and it is now back
to a big success.
Well it's a rather unusual
thing that a method that people
have put aside gets picked up
again and becomes a favorite,
as conjugate gradients have.
First of all, I was saying that
the basis, those basis vectors
are not very independent.
That's not a good basis.
Of course, it's a
detractive basis and maybe,
do you know the
name for a matrix
that has this particular form?
The columns are constant, then,
that's the key column, there,
and then it's first powers,
second powers, third powers.
Do you remember whose name is
associated with that matrix?
It comes up in interpolation,
and it starts with a V?
Anybody know?
Vandermonde, yeah.
Vandermonde.
So I could call it
V for Vandermonde.
And Vandermonde matrices are
not very well conditioned.
So now a little timeout to
say, because it's so important,
how do you judge the good or
poor conditioning of a matrix?
Those vectors are
linearly independent.
The determinant
of V is not zero.
The matrix is not singular,
but it's too close to singular,
and how do you test
the-- suppose you
have a basis, as we have here.
And you want to know
is it good or not?
So, of course, you always
put your bases vectors,
let me call them-- well,I don't
want to call them v because --
well I guess I
could call them v,
they come out of Vandermonde.
v_1, v_2, v_3, v_4.
That's our matrix.
Essentially I want
its condition number.
And to find its
condition number,
I-- it's not symmetric,
so I can't just
take the eigenvalues of that.
You might say, look at
lambda_max and lambda_min.
The condition
number is associated
with max divided by min.
But when the matrix
isn't symmetric,
just taking its eigenvalues
directly is not cool.
It's not reliable.
I could have a matrix
that's badly conditioned,
but all its eigenvalues were 1.
I mean a matrix with
1's on the diagonal
and zillions up
above the diagonal
would have eigenvalues of 1, but
it would be badly conditioned.
So the right way to take
it is V transpose V.
Look at v_1 transpose,
v_2 transpose...
As always, if a matrix
isn't symmetric,
if the matrix V
is not symmetric,
good idea to form V transpose
V. That is symmetric.
It does have
positive eigenvalues.
And those eigenvalues, the
eigenvalues of V transpose V,
are the singular values, or
rather the singular values
squared, of V. So
I guess I'm saying,
you can't trust the
eigenvalues of V.
It's the singular
values you can trust.
And the way to find
singular values
is form V transpose
V, that gives you
a symmetric matrix,
its eigenvalues--
so the i-th eigenvalue
would be the i-th singular
value squared.
So the condition number, is
sigma_max over sigma_min.
And, well, it's not enormous
for this 4 by 4 matrix,
but if I go up to 10
by 10 or 100 by 100.
100 by 100 would just
totally wipe me out.
10 by 10 would
already be disastrous.
Completely disastrous actually.
10 by 10 Vandermonde matrix,
with 1, 2 3, 4, up to 10
as the points, would be--
well, it would have entries--
if that ended in a
10 and I had 10 rows,
would that be something
like 10 to the ninth power.
I mean the dynamics
scale would be terrible.
So finally, just
to-- V transpose V
is called the Gram matrix.
So that guy Gram is coming back
in as giving the good measure.
So the point was then, that
this measures the dependence
or independence of the v's.
That ratio.
The bigger that ratio is,
the more dependency they are.
What's the ratio if
they're orthonormal?
What's the ratio of the q's?
What's the condition
number of the q's?
If we've run Arnoldi and
got a good basis, it's one.
What's the Gram matrix?
If this is Q transpose Q, with
the q's, the orthonormal basis
in the columns, then Q
transpose Q is the identity.
So it's a Gram matrix.
So Q transpose Q
would be the identity,
and its condition number
is the best possible one.
Lambda_max is 1,
lambda_min is 1.
The condition number is one.
OK.
So that's just some comments
about why Arnoldi gets brought
in to fix the situation.
OK.
So I'll just leave those ten
Arnoldi steps on the board.
The notes give ten comments.
I'm quite proud of-- my
MATLAB is unreliable.
Actually you'll
find a few errors
like after end, I
accidentally put
a semicolon, which was absurd.
But the comments
I'm pleased with,
and then the
numerical example that
runs through one cycle of
this, with these numbers,
to see what q_2 is,
is, I hope, useful.
Why do we have a
short recurrence?
This is a key point here.
And in this example, if I work
out the h's, I'll discover sure
enough, h_(1, 3) will be
0. h_(1, 4) will be 0.
Here's the key equation.
Here's Arnoldi in
matrix language.
Let me see if I can remember
Arnoldi in matrix language.
So, Arnoldi is taking
the matrix-- yeah.
So Arnoldi in matrix
language is going to be this.
It's going to A*Q equals Q*H.
I can't write out all of Q.
So that's the big equation.
Its a very important
equation that we now
have all the pieces for.
So A is our original
matrix that we were given.
Symmetric let's say.
Q is our basis out of Arnoldi
and H is the multipliers
that gave that basis.
So this Q*H is a little
bit like Gram-Schmidt.
Do you remember, Gram-Schmidt
is described by Q times R. Q,
again, is orthonormal.
So it's an orthogonal matrix.
In Gram-Schmidt R
is upper triangular.
Here it's not.
Here it's Hessenberg.
So H stands for Hessenberg.
I'll write down
what the actual H
is for these for these numbers.
I won't write down the
Q. I'll just write down
what H turned out to
be for those numbers
if I did it right.
Five halves.
Oh, interesting.
The lengths all turned
out to be five halves.
And this turned out
to be root 5 on 2.
This turned out to be the
square root of 4 over 5,
and this turned out to be
the square root of 9 over 20.
And the point is from here, this
one is just below the diagonal.
And it will show
up as symmetric.
Root 5 over 2, root
4/5 and root 9/20.
OK.
So, what am I seeing from
that particular H which
somehow can't be an accident?
It must be that it's built in.
It's the fact that H is
symmetric and tridiagonal.
And what does that
tridiagonal tell us?
It tells us that we
have short recurrences.
It's the three-term
recurrence relation,
is what I'm seeing here
in matrix language,
because there were three
non-zeros in the columns of H.
All right.
I was going to write
out-- I was going
to try to understand this one
by looking at the first column.
What if I take the first
column of both sides?
That'll be A times Q_1, right?
Q_1 is the first column vector
in the-- first basis vector.
And what do I have here
when I take q's times h's?
Do you do matrix multiplication
a column at a time?
You should.
OK.
So this says take 5/2
of the first column.
And this says take that factor
times the second column.
And I could track back
and see, yes that's
what Arnoldi has produced.
And then the second one, the
next one, would be an A*q_2.
the next would an A*q_3.
Well, look, here it is.
I want to show that H
is symmetric when A is.
Could you do that?
We know what the
property of Q is here.
We know that Q is, because
Arnoldi made it that way,
has Q transpose Q equal
I. And I can, in one step,
show that H is symmetric
if A is symmetric.
How do you do that?
I guess we need a
formula for H, so I just
multiply by Q inverse.
So that's good.
And even better is to
recognize what Q inverse is.
So what is Q inverse here?
It's Q transpose.
Anytime we see Q, that's
my letter, always,
for an orthogonal matrix.
So this is Q transpose
A Q. And now what?
The argument's finished.
We're here.
If A is symmetric, what can
you say about that combination?
If A is a symmetric matrix?
It is symmetric.
Right?
That's how you get the
symmetric matrices.
You start with one.
You multiply on one side by a
matrix, and on the other side
by its transpose.
The thing has to be
symmetric, because if I
transpose this whole
thing, what will happen?
To transpose things
their transposes
come in the opposite order.
So Q, its transpose comes first.
A, its transpose comes in
the middle, but what's that?
The transpose of A is A. We're
assuming A to be symmetric.
And then the transpose
of Q transpose is?
Is Q.
So we got this back
again when we transpose,
so it's symmetric.
So H is symmetric.
So the conclusion is,
H equals H transposed.
And then we know immediately
that it's tridiagonal,
because every H from
Arnoldi is Hessenberg.
We know that these
zeros are here.
The Arnoldi cycle ended
produced h i j in column j
but it's stopped one
below the diagonal.
So we know these are
zero, but now, if we know
the matrix is symmetric,
then we know these are zero.
And, of course, it
works out that way.
So the conclusion is that we
can orthogonalize the Krylov
basis, quickly, easily,
and work with that basis,
either explicitly
by computing it
or by implicitly by
keeping things orthogonal
and that's what conjugate
gradients will do.
So next time, I'm
going to make an effort
to describe the conjugate
gradients method.
I'll pick the highlights of it.
It has fantastic properties,
and to verify those properties
in full detail is often
more confusing than not.
If you see today's
lecture, you're
seeing the important
points: the role of symmetry
of A and the Arnoldi algorithm.
OK. so that's our first
lecture on the Krylov ideas.
And next time, we'll
probably complete that topic,
and it will be on the web.
So I'll see you Wednesday
for the end of Krylov.
Thanks.
Good.